so today we're going to try energy shot
and longest Chrysler Cirrus II here that
they are the same drink and we need to
get to the bottom we're back energy shot
versus long expresso are they different
are they the same which one's better
we're going to find out okay
I'm confused again I don't have a
delicate enough talent for coffee I
don't know I think this one's stronger
I think mug Express is stronger which
one tastes better this is more watered
down this is stronger I think this
tastes better
alright IV I don't like strong coffee
YV is a coffee hater for me the federal
version would be the more watered
operations
[Music]
it looks so bad but I think energy shop
strong expertise we should disagree with
you penny where's your pension so I'm a
daily dream girl blah go spread stuff so
I shouldn't know exactly the way tastes
like okay yeah yep oh yeah this
definitely is more water brought to me I
don't care not espresso is more bitter
this is the choice so but in the end we
all like this one the best the long and
long espresso wins we we did it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]